I have a voicemail number that you can
call any time of day the number is two
one nine to david p let's take a listen
to this voicemail that came in well
David thanks for your show I really
enjoyed watching and screwing your
opinions but I've got a question I'm
just wondering if all bullies kind of
like you know trumpsta bully if all
beliefs turn into crybabies when they
don't get their way think about it have
a good evening yeah it's interesting
because uh Donald Trump is a bully in
many many ways but he does seem to turn
into a crybaby when things don't go his
way uh he has these insane Twitter
meltdowns that are that are just
absolutely in said you know they make no
sense they're childish and capricious in
every way anytime he loses as Hillary
Clinton did point out yesterday the
election is rigged everybody scamming
everybody tricked Trump everybody's plot
playing fair when Donald Trump doesn't
even himself have a particularly strong
record of playing by the rules and
playing fairs was also pointed out in
yesterday's debate everything from
bringing in Chinese steel etcetera
etcetera so no I don't know that all
bullies become crybabies when things
don't go their way but certainly Donald
Trump the bully has become a total
crybaby when things have got not gone
his way on the bonus show today I have
such a great story for you on the bonus
show here from Las Vegas yesterday when
I was walking to dinner or to an event
that was part of the conference I was
stopped by someone who recognized me and
was a fan of the show and let's just say
that the story involves a fan of the
david pakman show a US ambassador and a
former major league baseball player okay
that's all I will say I'll tell the
whole story on the bonus show and I
think you're really going to like the
story we will also talk about the future
of the david pakman show town halls and
i will also tell you about a new idea
involving seaweed and cows too
herb global greenhouse gas emissions it
is such a terrific bonus show today
believe me trust me on this it's
extraordinary and you can sign up by
going to david pakman.com slash
membership that is the one and only
place to sign up for membership and i
will mention to you the coupon code hey
tree at 40 that's h80 our iot 40 it's
available and it gets you a really nice
discount off of membership don't miss my
Vegas story from last night sign up I
will speak to you that